j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré aux conséquences
notamment politiques de l'assassinat
terroriste de Dominique Bernard
professeur de lettre à haras son
assaillant à fich s né en inoui était
surveillé par la DGSI pourquoi
n'était-il pas expulsable son geste est
lié on y revient au conflit
israéliopistinien premers éléments de
réponse grâce à Cécile Siou en 2014
Mohammed m ses parents et ses quatre
frères et sœurs auraient dû quitter le
territoire les moguchenov originaires
d'ingushi en Russie sont sous le coup
d'une mesure d'expulsion la France
refuse de leur donner l'asile mais les
associations vont mettre la pression
finalement aucun membre de la famille ne
va monter dans l'avion manuel Vals qui
était ministre de l'Intérieur s'explique
à ce moment-là mon cabinet a considéré
que la famille qui était là depuis plus
de 5 ans qui avait des enfants
scolarisés cette famille répondait au
critères de ce qu'on a app la circulaire
Vals concernant les sans papierers les
expulsions d'enfants voilà donc elle n'a
pas été elle n'a pas été expulsée
aujourd'hui la famille est bien connue
des services de renseignement le père
d'abord fichier s il a été expulsé en
2018 le frère aîné ensuite radicalisé
est en prison quant à Mohamed m
l'assaillant il a été fiché s le 2
octobre dernier mais arrivé en France
avant 13 ans il n'était pas expulsable
une position que regrette géralde
daranin et que prévoit de modifier son
projet de loi immigration projet de loi
nous permettrait c'est pour ça qu'il
faut adopter cette loi désormais très
vite de pouvoir expulser du territoire
national des personnes qui pourtant
jusqu'à présent sont protégé parce qu'on
appelle des réserves d'ordre publique
pour Jordan Bardella ce projet de loi ne
va pas assez loin il réclame plus de
fermeté vous êtes sur le sol français
vous êtes accueilli par la générosité la
bienveillance du peuple français vous
avez un lien avec l'idéologie islamiste
vous devez être renvoyé dans votre pays
d'origine il y a 4000 individus qui sont
fich qui sont de nationalité étrangères
ils doivent être sans délai expulsés à
gauche en revanche c'est une loi de plus
et pas une solution ce n'est pas vrai
qu'il a besoin de changer la législation
pour éventuellement le père d'ailleurs
avait été expulsé et le jeune homme qui
depuis est devenu un adulte pouvait
l'êre qu'on ne vous fasse pas le coup à
l'occasion d'un drame de textes qui
passent à côté du sujet qui sont des
textes d'agitation texte d'agitation en
tout cas le projet de loi plusieurs fois
repoussé découpé et recollé par le
gouvernement faute de majorité devrait
cette fois trouver une certaine
légitimité que peut faire la France face
à cette menace terroriste on répond à
cette question avec mes invités
Jean-Michel fauberg bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue ancien chef du Raid ancien
député la République en marche et auteur
de ce livre les hommes en noir publié
aux éditions plomb Frédéric Ploquin
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous aussi vous
êtes journaliste d'investigation
spécialiste euh de la police et du
renseignement et vous publiez ce
mercredi les réseaux secrets de la
police livre qui sort aux éditions
Nouveau Monde Pascal Perino bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes politologue et
professeur à Sciences Po Paris on est
également en duplexe avec Florent
vadiillot qui est président du cercle de
réflexion léérie et enseignant à
sciencep bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
Mathieu croissand est évidemment resté à
mes côtés euh pour ouvrir ce débat je
vous propose une une réaction celle de
Jean-François Ricard le procureur
national antiterroriste écoutez
plusieurs témoins ont entendu l'auteur
crié Allah Akbar au cours de ces
faits il était connu pour sa
radicalisation il était inscrit au
fichiers des signalements pour la
prévention de la radicalisation
terroriste et un de ses frères de 2 ans
son aîné dont il est proche avait été
condamné en avril 2023 par la Cour
d'assise de Paris pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes criminel et non
dénonciation de
crime Jean-Michel fauberg on l'a compris
cette famille elle était repérée
surveiller également alors sauf que
surveiller arrêter expulser on va
comprendre autour de ce débat que c'est
pas si simple d'enchaîner ces trois
verbes est-ce qu'il y a eu pour vous
malgré tout une faille des services de
renseignement
alors je suis pas à l'intérieur même de
des services des services de
renseignement
euh euh ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que il a il étit suivi par les servic de
renseignement en particulier le le le
l'agresseur a été suivi et et d'une
manière d'une manière constante depuis
qu'il était sous sous surveillance eu il
a été relâché ou du moins il n'a pas été
interpellé parce qu'il avait rien à lui
reprocher à ce moment h mais en fait ça
c'est juste la veille de cette de de de
cet assassinat et de cette attaque
terroriste en réalité il faut remonter
beaucoup plus tôt et moi je pense que
tout à fait tout simple tout à fait
simplement si l'ensemble de la famille
avait été expulsé en 2014 mais il y
aurait pas eu de il y aurait pas eu ce
crime là sur notre territoire national
il faut il faut revoir un peu la manière
dont les choses sont faites en en 2014
euh manuel Vals est revenu dessus mais
il faut approfondir un peu sur sur la
manière dont ça s'est fait en réalité
l'expulsion était quasi quasi faite on a
eu un certain nombre de d'associations
qui s'y sont
opposé comme elles s'opposent d'une
manière générale dans tous les cas c'est
leur manière de faire sont des
associations quoi de défense de d'aide
au réfugiés vous aviez la SIMAD vous
aviez le le réseau de d'éducation sans
frontières vous av vous en aviez
d'autres vous avez même le le le le le
Parti communiste local qui s'est opposé
à tout ça mais c'est une manière de
faire qui est traditionnelle la
problématique c'est que l'État a était
faible là-dessus c'est que l'État s plié
à ce que ces associations ont voulu on a
gardé ces ces étrangers là qui qui est
expulsable et il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé al on y reviendra au rôle
des associations si vous voulez bien
mais effectivement c'était important dè
votre première intervention de remonter
un peu dans dans le dans le temps
Frédéric Ploquin il attaque comme
celle-là ce qu'on comprend c'est la la
difficulté même quand il y a une
surveillance même quand la DGSI est est
et sur cette famille d'une certaine
façon on est dans un état de droit on
peut pas les arrêter avant que avant
qu'il y ait eu un un acte c'est ça la
difficulté des policiers mais avant de
parler de faille des services des
services de sécurité on peut saluer tout
simplement le fait que les services de
sécurité avaient repéré cet individu
c'est quand même le rôle d'un service de
renseignement de repérer les individus
donc ça c'est le premier point ça je
suis 100% d'accord avec vous après après
après r l'êch je rappelle que la plupart
des individus qui passent à l'acte en
matière de terrorisme islamique
islamiste en sur le sur le sol français
sont fichers s c'estd qu'en fait on les
connaît on les identifie mais fichers s
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire fichers s ça
veut pas dire coupable oui fichers s ça
veut dire suspect à partir du moment où
dans le droit français vous avez un
suspect on va pas faire un Guantanamo
dans le lot pour l'enfermer non on en
est pas là en France on a des règles de
droit qu'on applique et cetera donc il
est suspect c'est déjà pas mal après
vous savez ce qui se passe moi moi je je
remarque là on a cet attentat à à haras
je rappelle que il y a TR ou 4atre jours
on se on était encore dans le procès de
l'attentat de maganville que en
septembre en janvier prochain en février
nous aurons le procès de l'attentat de
Strasbourg que nous sommes à un an de
celui de Samuel petit donc on peut
parler là on n'est pas je c'est terrible
à dire je voudrais pas qu'on s'habitue
aux attentats mais n'empêche qu'on en a
sans arrêt et à partir de là le
phénomène qui se produit c'est plutôt un
phénomène de submersion c'estàdire que
si vous avez 3000 fichiers à surveiller
et que vous avez une des effectifs de la
DGSI à mettons 5000 ils sont environ
5000 5000 membres déjà pour surveiller
en permanence ces 3000
individus il non c'est pas ça c'est
c'est pas dimensionné si il y a une
submersion il y a beaucoup trop de monde
à surveiller aujourd'hui et en fait
c'est ce que pratiquent les islamistes
c'est un peu ce que font les trafiquants
de stupéfiants à leur manière sur le
territoire c'est la saturation les
trafiquants de stupéfiants ont saturé le
territ français et les services de
police ont ont beau se remettre en cause
se dimensionner il n'y arrivrient pas et
bien c'est un peu la même chose et
aujourd'hui donc on a une une saturation
qui rend extrêmement juste en un mot la
filature la surveillance permanente d'un
individu soupçonné de passer à l'acte
c'est au minimum 5 6 fonctionnaires pour
48 he donc vous imaginez le nombre là on
est je sais pas combien de fichiers
10000 15000 on est un nombre infini de
fichiers d'accord donc à partir de là
pour vraiment leur mettre un fil à la
patte et et en fait les surveill à
chaque fois qu'ils sortent de de chez
eux il faut il faudrait il faudrait un
nombre de fonctionnaires que nous
n'avons pas donc faut peut-être penser
la manière d'appréhender cette cette
matière je vais vous donner la parole
sur les les conséquences politiques
Pascal P mais je voudrais d'abord me
tourners vers Florent vadiillot parce
que vous parlez de terrorisme low cost
Florent vadiillot pourquoi cette
expression ben le terrorisme lowcost
c'est en réalité un terrorisme avec peu
ou pas de
complicité peu ou pas d'actes
préparatoire et puis un un mode
opératoire qui ne ti pas de financement
particulier l'attaque au couteau
l'attaque au marteau il y a quelques
années de cela et donc ce ce terrorisme
là en fait c'est c'est celui qui est le
plus efficace parce que à la fois le
plus
difficilement détectable ou en tout cas
arrêtable au sens judiciaire du terme
puisque les actes préparatoires sont
inexistants et la complicité quasi
inexistante et puis c'est celui qui a le
plus d'effets parce que l'effet ne se
mesure pas au nombre de morts il se
mesure à la symbolique de de la mort et
puis à la récurrence des des décès par
des faits d'attentat donc il a en
réalité tous les avantages si jeose dire
du terrorisme et aucun des inconvénients
des grandes structures c'est donc le un
terrorisme effectivement d'une
efficacité assez redoutable Pascal
Perino on reviendra effectivement sur le
rôle des associations et cetera mais euh
on a le sentiment de d'une d'une réponse
quasi impossible de de de de de l'État
ou en tout cas de sa police face à ce ce
type de terrorisme qu'est-ce que vous en
P oui en effet quand vous regardez les
enquêtes d'opinion d'ailleurs la
population française qui est très
inquiète hein je regardais dans le la
dernière enquête Ifop c'est trois
Français sur quatre euh qui estim que le
conflit a des répercussions des
répercussions graves euh sur la vie
politique et et la situation en France
donc il y a une population extrêmement
inquiète mais il y a une population qui
qui intègre la relative impuissance de
pourtant de celle qui se définit comme
étant la la puissance publique et on
vient d'en voir les les les ressorts
hein en effet on ne peut pas mettre
derrière une dizaine de milliers de
fichiers s cinq fonctionnaires les
effectifs ne sont pas là et les Français
le savent très bien mais les Français
sont aussi inquiets parce qu'ils se
disent que c'est euh c'estes loups
solitaires alors sont-ils si solitaires
que ça d'ailleurs on le verra dans
l'enquête c'estes loup solitaires
bénéficie tout de même d'un
environnement qui est non pas
potentiellement terroriste mais qui ne
porte pas un regard profondément négatif
sur ce terrorisme hein il y a une partie
en effet et des enquêtes l'ont montré
quantitativ de la jeunesse
française qui est sensible à ce recours
à la violence et en particulier parmi
les jeunes issus de
l'immigration alors c'est pas du tout
des terroristes po
mais comment dire il n'arrive pas à
condamner et on le voit très bien dans
l'école publique des professeurs ont été
lors de la sinistre affaire Samuel pati
confronté à cette
rétiscence de la part d'une partie des
effectifs de collégiens à voilà observer
une minute de silence
pouruel c'est ça la question matthie en
effet c'est très difficile de est-ce
qu'il n'arrive pas à condamner les actes
terroristes où est-ce qu'il n'arrive pas
à condamner les actes terroristes commis
au nom d'une atteinte à la laïcité ce
qui est un petit peu différent c'est
est-ce que Nice il y a pas de rapport
avec la laïcité Samuel Patti il y a un
rapport avec la laïcité là en effet il y
a une partie certainement de de ces
jeunes qui se sent mal à l'aise avec les
règles de la laïcité euh au sein de
l'école de l'école publique c'est pour
ça que l'école publique c'est même très
frappant moi qui suis professeur je m'en
rends compte l'école publique est
soumise
j'allais dire à une critique assez
acerbe de ces milieux et c'est là où on
recense maintenant les principales
victimes du moins les victimes les plus
les plus symboliques est-ce que on est
dans une forme d'importation du conflit
israélo-palestinien fr plin est-ce qu'il
y a il y a une dans dans ce qui
déclenche parce que là on décrit
finalement des processus de de de de de
radicalisé un peu d'orment et puis à un
moment où malheureusement il déclenche
leur acte est-ce qu' voilà est-ce qu'il
y a un élément c'est cl un lien c'est
c'est c'est pas tout à fait un loup
solitaire d'abord il a un frère aîné qui
doit auquel il doit s'identifier qui
lui-même été condamné plusieurs fois
pour terrorisme lui-même il a déjà eu
des ennuis et apparemmentprès que
commence à dire l'enquête il était en en
lien par les réseaux sociaux avec un un
converti ce sont les pires les convertis
incarcéré dans une prison en France qui
arrêtait pas de le de le solliciter pour
passer à l'acte et qui saurait faire ce
ce converti qui apparemment prêche dans
la prison est devenu une sorte de
prédicateur il fait référence sans arrêt
ça il mélange tout hein c'est un boulg
boulgar en fait il ils connaissent rien
au Coran la plupart du temps ils savent
même pas le lire ils parlent pas arabe
bien souvent mais en revanche il y a des
petits mots comme ça qui a Palestine
machin et le gars qui était en train de
leur monter la tête effectivement il
utilisait sans cesse le mot Palestine
ils savent je sais même pas s'il savent
où ça se trouve à la limite c'est pas
grave mais c'est espèce de l'idée c'est
de de générer chez eux une volonté de
vengeance et de passage à l'acte et un
dernier point la chose qui est utilisée
par ceux qui retournent le cerveau de
nos jeunes la première chose ce sont des
images des images à qui on fait tout
dire des images souvent tronquées des
images d'horreur et en fait il jouent à
fond en permanence sur les images d'or
donc effectivement là on a eu des images
en masse qui sont arrivées de Gaza ou
d'Israël horrible terrible et il jouent
là-dessus et et ils alimentent ils
alimentent le en fait ils essaient de
toucher la la corde la plus la plus
vicieuse de l'homme pour le faire
basculer et lui dire passe passe à
l'acte vas-y vengles c'est comme ça que
ça se passe d'accord Jean-Michel fa la
France était c'est on parle donc de ces
terroristes dormant loup solitaire ou
pas et cetera mais la France éit plus
touché que que ses voisins européens est
que parce que c'est très difficile à à
conttabiliser en fait ce qu'il y a de
sûr c'est qu'en France il y a un Terrero
propice dans dans les banlieux et
ailleurs d'ailleurs euh sur cette cette
radicalité on est passé
d'un en 2015 d'un d'un système
d'attentat projeté de de l'extérieur et
à l'intérieur du pays à un
système interne à notre are pays et
d'ailleurs les services de de
renseignement aujourd'hui craignent
aussi que le le le les attentats
projetés ne reviennent ils ont ils ont
quelques quelques craintes là-dessus
mais pour l'instant on est dans un
Terrero qui est très propice on n'est
pas le seul pays on a on a la Belgique
autour de nous voire même la l'Allemagne
mais la France est un pays qui de par
son histoire de par de par sa culture et
et véritablement ce terraro là alors
effectivement en plus c'est un c'est un
Terrero
en général dans les banlieux pas que
mais en général dans les banlieux euh où
les gens euh ou ceux qui sont qui qui
qui ont tendance à aller vers ce vers
cette direction là se victimisent assez
rapidement euh pour certains ils sont
déjà des délinquants et et donc ils
essayent de trouver à bas à bas bruit
une espèce de de de de nouvelle ligne
morale ou en tout cas une c certaine
formme de religiosité euh qui va leur
euh voilà les remettre dans dans dans un
espèce de de chemin qui est un chemin
qui est pas le droit chemin mais qui est
un chemin euh de violence et donc il ne
il ils ne ils ne perdent pas l'habitude
qu'ils ont à à être violent et donc ce
passage à l'AE est est est simplifié de
cette manière-là en réalité les
islamistes ce qu'on fait les islamistes
sur notre territoire comme ailleurs
c'est que les islamistes ont pris en
otage l'islam dans un premier temps et
sont en train de de prendre en otage les
musulmans ou ceux
qui se se
se se revendique de ça quoi et en
particulier les plus jeunes voilà où on
en est aujourd'hui alors la réponse
politique elle est évidemment très
compliquée Mathieu on va s'intéresser au
mot choisis par le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron qui a demandé
ce weekend à ses ministres d'incarner un
état impitoyable en verers je le cite
tous ceux qui portent la haine et des
idéologies pardon terroristes oui
impitoyable le mot est fort il a été
soign ement distillé à la presse hier
par l'Élysée et on voit bien l'idée au
fond d'afficher une fermeté sans faille
d'abord pour tenter de rassurer les
Français qui sont légitimement inquiet
et puis ensuite pour tenter de couper
l'erbre sous le pied de l'opposition qui
nourrit déjà des procès en laxisme et en
impuissance alors c'est important les
mots on l'a vu la semaine dernière avec
les difficultés de certains élus à
nommer le mal mais le problème c'est que
même les mots forts n'évitent pas les
drames tenz c'est pas la première fois
qu'immanuel Macron emploie cet adjectif
il avait déjà prévenu que la République
se montrerait impitoyable avec avec les
porteurs de haine c'était quand c'était
jeudi soir la veille de l'assassinat de
Dominique Bernard haras lors de son
aglocution à Emmanuel Macron à la
télévision alors faut dire les mot
justes faut aussi passer aux actes
efficaces et c'est tout le défi qui
attend l'exécutif désormais alors que la
France voit ressurgir sur son sol le
cauchemar terroriste est-ce qu'on peut
dire pour autant que rien n'a été fait
non on peut pas dire ça parce qu'il y a
eu depuis l'assassinat de Samuel paatti
en tout cas des lois il y a une loi qui
a été prise pour lutter contre les
séparatistes il a une nouvelle loi qui a
été prise pour prévenir les actes de
terrorisme et c'est une loi sur le
renseignement il y a eu des lois qui ont
été prises aussi pour mieux euh lutter
contre la haine en ligne du côté de
l'éducation nationale il y a eu des
équipes valeurs de la République qui ont
été constituées il y a eu des
professeurs qui ont été formés il y a eu
un vadmcom de la laïcité qui a été revu
il y a de des des protocoles de séc de
sécurisation pardon dans les
établissements on l'a vu à race hein et
qui fonctionne d'ailleurs alors on peut
encore les améliorer on peut mettre des
caméras des vigiles des portiques comme
le dit Gabriel Atal peut-être sans tabou
on peut aussi revoir notre droit de
l'immigration ce sera d'ailleurs l'objet
du prochain débat qui s'ouvre en
novembre au Sénat pour réparer les trous
dans la raquette comme on dit et puis
mettre fin surtout à cette
incompréhension absolue des Français qui
veut que un individu puisse être jugé
dangereux et fiché et jugé expulsable
mais ne le soit pas dans les faits on
peut aussi mieux relever les signaux
faibles mieux communiquer entre les
administrations tout ça oui mais c'est
autant de chantiers nécessaires mais qui
ne sont pas sans risque pourquoi quels
sont ces risques parce qu'il y a deux
yatus le premier il est entre l'exécutif
et l'opinion publique aucune loi aucune
mesure ne pourra jamais garantir qu'il y
aura aucun attentat terroriste l'étaat
ne peut remplir sur ce point qu'une
obligation de moyens et encore on l'a vu
on peut pas mettre des gendarmes
derrière tous les terroristes potentiels
mais les Français ils sont inquiets
sidérés exaspérés et eux ils attendent
plutôt une obligation de résultat Pascal
Perino il faisait allusion tout à
l'heure et puis le deuxième iatus c'est
que dans ce climat de surenchère ben
cette demande de protection légitime des
Français elle peut Horter aussi nos
valeurs nos principes on se souvient de
ce qui s'est passé avec le patriote acte
aux États-Unis on voit bien que entre
l'obligation de résultat et la défense
de nos valeurs et ben le chemin devient
de plus en plus étroit alors il il y a
quand même si si on compare C vous
l'avez évoqué il y a 3 ans jour pour
jour que Samuel Patti était assassiné à
Conflant saintonoris par un jeune
d'origine chenen là on est 3 ans après
et c'est un jeune d'origine inouche on
est dans la même région dans le dans le
nord du Caucase donc forcément Florent
vadiillot ça ça pose cette question de
d'une accusation d'inertie ou
d'impuissance de de du gouvernement que
que peut répondre Emmanuel Macron à
cette
accusation rien etélas rien et en tout
cas tous ceux qui essaieront d'avoir le
le d'entrer dans le concours l'épine de
la de la meilleure solution pour réduire
à néant le risque terroriste quel qu'il
soit d'où qu'ils viennent exogène ou
endogène se heurteront en fait à des
incapacités de faire il n'y a pas de
dispositif technologique ouou législatif
qui permettent d'empêcher un individu de
de passer à l'acte ce qui estime que
l'expulsion systématique des personnes
dangereuses éteindra la menace
terroriste ce be d'illusion c'est il y a
une régularité statistique certes mais
permettez-moi quand même sans volonté de
relativisation cette régularité
statistique elle porte sur deux faits
terroristes à plusieurs en tout cas au
moins 2 années d'écart ce qui ce qui
n'encit pas si vous voulez un phénomène
du d'un caractère implacable je pense
qu'on a un dispositif sécuritaire et
législatif qui est extrêmement complet
et que le risque zéro n'existe pas donc
il y a peut-être ensuite une question de
maîtrise de la population sur le
territoire de de facilitation des règles
d'expulsion mais permettez-moi de le
signaler la France n'est pas pieds et
points lié en la matière et elle n'est
tenu au demeurant par aucun accord
internationaux puisque le ministre
d'armanin s'est même vanté de ne pas
respecter les obligations de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme en la
matière donc l'impuissance n'est pas
n'est ni une impuissance subie ni
orchestrée elle est en réalité une une
Forté c'est il y a des moments où vous
ne pouvez pas lutter contre un passage à
l'acte et et je crois qu'il faut essayer
de raison garder sur ce dispositif là
par j'entends votre argument Florent VO
mais politiquement c'est enfin va pas
être naïf c'est impossible il va bien
falloir une il faudra une réponse mais
pardon th je me permets quand même de
rappeler que en 1986 c'était plusieurs
attentats par semaine avec à la chaque
fois 5 à 20 morts il y a 40 ans notre
société était capable avec un esprit de
rés ance d'encaisser euh ce ces ces
chocsl en en ayant des modifications
très faibles du dispositif législatif
elles étaient sans doute trop faible à
l'époque mais posons-nous la question de
ce qui a dérapé dans notre capacité
d'encaisser des traumas nationaux comme
un acte terroriste en 40 ans de
différence je pense qu'il faut aussi que
l'esprit de résilience qui doit habiter
la société et que les responsables
politiques doivent promouvoir doit
permettre d'essayer de de tenir le
barrage lorsqu'il y a des événements
traumatiques je sais que ça n'est pas un
discours mainstream ça n'est pas dans
l'air du temps mais je crois qu'il faut
le rappeler qu'il y a un devoir de
responsabilité Pascal Perino qu-ce que
est-ce que vous vous entendez les
arguments de Florent illot est-ce qu'on
a perdu alors je je simplifie hein
pardon Florent mais un peu de cet esprit
de résilience si vous voulez quand le
terrorisme devient récurrent quand le
terrorisme
intérieur se passe dans un contexte
international et extérieur extrêm
perturbé qui touche directement la
Communauté française hein n'oublions pas
le nombre d'otages pris par le Hamas qui
ont la nationalité française le nombre
de morts français à la suite de
l'attaque du Hamas tout ça crée un écho
dans la population française tout à fait
important et il est légitime même si
l'opinion connaît les limites il est
légitime que l'opinion attente de la
part de l'État une réponse cette réponse
va aller dans le sens d'un durcissement
ce qui semblait peut-être impossible
hier sur le projet de loi immigration va
devenir possible demain et quand on
regarde toutes les enquêtes on
s'aperçoit qui tire son son épingle du
jeu politiquement dans le jeu politique
national vous vous apercevez que
l'attitude de la France insoumise qui a
beaucoup relativisé et profondément
sanctionné par les français a commencé
par les é ur qui ont voté à gauche et
qui ne pardonnent pas à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'attitude qui est considéré
comme ambigu qu'il a pu prendre et ceux
qui tirent leur épingle du jeu et bien
c'est essentiellement la droite et au
sein de la droite le rassemblement
national on y reviendra sur le le projet
de l' immigration mais je voudrais quand
même qu'on qu'on prenne quelques minutes
pour parler de ces
théroriste venu du Caucase puisque le
président de la République lui-même
Féric plquin a demandé je cite he une
approche spécialisée pour les jeunes
hommes de 16 25 ans originaires du
Caucase euh je crois qu'il y a environ
40000 personnes réfugies qui ont été
accueilliis en France en 2014 à peu près
euh pas tous n'ont pas obtenu le statut
de réfugié politique mais en gros
c'était 40000 c'était au moment où où
Moscou avait décidé de d'en découdre
avec la la tchenie on en a accueilli
40000 sur les 40000 sont pas force
j'espère que ce sont pas tous des
terroristes potentiels mais cette
famillelà qui est passée à l'acte à Don
don le jeune homme la famille du jeune
homme qui est passé à laacte à haras
elle a été tout de suite repérée et
d'ailleurs le le père et c'est peutêtre
je sais pas c'est peut-être une des
raisons de le père le le le papa de tous
ces garçons a été expulsé très
rapidement en réalité parce que la
famille n'avait pas pu l'être mais le
père a été expulsé en Belgique et la
Belgique l'a tout de suite mis dans un
avion pour pour la Russie donc ils ont
perdu ce ce père qui lui-même avait
inculqué leur avait inculqué ses valeurs
mais après euh ils étaient ils étaient
tout petits à ce moment-là je veux dire
faut je moi ce que je remarque c'est
c'est tous c tous ces terroristes ils
sont est après 2000 ils ont même pas ils
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui qui est
intéressant que vous faites référence
quand vous quand vous dites 40000 je
crois que c'était une note de la DGSI
d'octobre 2020 qui qui donnait
effectivement une fourchette c'était la
partie haute de la 400 terroristes non
bien sûr que non évidemment que non on
se on se on se méfie ici de tous les
amgam mais ce surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette génération
là elle est différente dans sa dérive
islamiste de celle des des parents qui
eux étaient dans un combat local en
cheeni contre
justementette génration dis fin ils
sensi au arguments de l'éat Islamist sur
sur Internet et cetera et génraation
déjà très jeunes ils ont été marqués par
la guerre ça c'est important ils ont
vécu la guerre ils ont vécu l'exil ils
ont vécu B tout ce que vous voulez donc
ils sont assez traumatisé au départ et
là-dessus il suffit de pas grand-chose
pour pour leur imposer pour leur
inculquer un certain nombre de choses et
c'est clair que apparemment ils ont pas
été sensibles aux valeurs de la
République parce qu'ils sont quand même
allé à l'école mais ils ont pas été
sensibles au valeurs de la République et
moi ce que je remarque c'est c'est
vraiment ce qui fédère tous ces tous ces
jeunes gens c'est que non seulement ils
sont pas sensibles aux valeurs de la
République mais ils les rejettent et moi
je crois quand même que ce qu'il
partagent le plus c'est une vraie il
faut l'admettre il faut l'accepter il
faut le dire une vraie détestation de la
France moi je je je leur parle je les
côtois je parfois je vais en voir en
prison parfois je il haïent il déteste
tout ce que représente la France et et
DAEs joue là-dessus à fond parce que
daesh je dire nous nous la France nous
sommes finalement le meilleur ennemi de
daesh au fond pourquoi parce que tout ce
que nous représentons tout ce que nous
défendons toute cette laïcité cette
façon d'empêcher un certain nombre de de
vêtements de dissimuler les de défendre
la femme de défendre les femmes tout ça
c'est ce sur quoi ce contre quoi ils
combattent et et donc c'est c'est
relativement facile après d'aller
d'aller porter le combat dans ce pays et
d'aller d'aller réveiller comme ça c'est
finalement ce sont des enfants qui
savent même pas où enfin ils savent pas
d'où ils viennent je lingoui il la
connaî pas ce ce jeune homme il connaît
pas la culture il a pas de sa culture
d'origine il a plus il a pas adopté la
culture française il est perdu entre
deux eos et là il y a un gars qui qui
depuis la prise lui envoie des petits
messages viens suis-moi tu vois on les
déteste c'est les salots on va les avoir
il faut les tuer parce que en fait il y
a vraiment une ENF c'est vraiment des
appel au meurtres il faut tuer le entre
guillemets mécréant parce que nous
sommes nous Français tous d'affreux
mécréant lacar de sur C c'est ça c'est
ça la réalité je reviens je remonte le
temps comme vous l'avez fait tout à
l'heure pour pour revenir en 2014
Jean-Michel fauerg vous n l'avez dit il
y avait eu une procédure de d'expulsion
de la famille mugchov avait qui est
engagé euh plusieurs associations
s'étaient opposé à ça et effectivement
des militants communistes vous l'avz dit
regardez ces images qui nous viennent de
Renn et c'est un groupuscule d'ultra
droite qui a revendiqué sur son compte x
enfin Twitter avoir vandalisé le le
portail du local de ce de parti
communiste à Rennes l'accusant de
soutenir voilà on voit les on voit les
les tags les assassins islamistes après
l'attentat d'aras
euh là on est dans un terrain de
récupération idéale Pascal pierinon on
va on va y venir mais vous vous nous
dites les associations sont dans leur
rôle et l'État a été faible j'aimerais
que vous détaillez ce que ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure les associations
sont d'une manière générale il y a un
certain nombre d'associations la simade
le le Secours Catholique et Cera qui
sont des associations qui au départ on
connaît leur histoire l'une protestante
catholique et puis il y en a d'autres
qui sont des associations qui qui sont
là pour aider les gens en difficulté ère
générale par contre es ont ce type
d'association pas uniquement celle-là
mais ce type d'association on glisser au
fur et à mesure sur une propag une
propagande alors peut-être
par je sais pas par par ignorance un
certain nombre de choses ou par bonne
foi pour certains ou véritablement parce
qu'ils sont mus politiquement
aussi sur un
transfonttialisme
exacerbé ces associ
là
pour celle qui qui a été cité plus
d'autes s'oppose à systématiquement
s'oppose souvent s'oppose souvent à
à au retour forcé aux mesures
d'expulsion d'autres d'autres ramènent
chez nous un certain nombre de de de de
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière en
fait la la la la cohérence de de de
ces associations là se dans ce dans ce
combat là la la la et elles sont dans
son rôle dans dans leur rôle parce que
elles sont dans dans un combat qui et
quelquefois un combat politique sont
éloigné de ok j'entends mais l'État mais
pour le coup l'État pourrait ne passer
la problématique la problématique de de
de notre état c'est que depuis des
années et des années et ça date pas
d'hier elles ont elles cèdent à ces
associations là d'une manière générale
et pas que notre état à nous on le voit
aussi au confin des frontières
européenne en en Italie en Italie même
avec avec le gouvernement que que qu'on
a de manière actuelle voilà c'est on est
dans un dans un état faible d'une
manière générale parce que parce que nos
démocraties euh sont sont à la limite
des libertés et de la lutte contre
contre ce ce ce ce genre de ce genre de
chose il faut faut revenir à quelque
chose de plus fort pour rappeler aussi
qu' beaucoup de ces associations alors
je parle pas du Secours catholique ou de
la sane mais du Réseau éducation sans
frontières sont né aussi au début des
années 2000 où on éétait pas dans cette
ambiance terroriste parce que
l'immigration c'est aussi ce sont aussi
des histoires humaines même quand c'est
l'immigration irrégulière et le Réseau
éducation sans frontière il est né il a
joui plutôt d'une assez forte popularité
auprès des parents DF parce qu'il disait
ben pourquoi le petit gamin qui est
copain de mon fils il est expulsé demain
c'est dégueulasse et donc voilà on a
bénéficié aussi ça fa ses mouvements ont
bénéficié à l'époque de de cette
mobilisation là pour venir en aide à des
sans papiers mais qui considéré intégrés
parce que les gamins allaient l'école et
que S souvent les les parents
travaillaient c'était pas du tout une
logique de terrorisme et l'État avait
sans doute une faiblesse parce qu'il
n'appliquait pas ses textes mais c'était
pas une faiblesse laxiste en terme de
sécurité parce que personne n'imaginait
à l'époque encore une fois que que que
ces enfantsl on est sur le même résultat
en fait d'une manière j'entends bien
j'entends bien mais je dis juste c'était
pas une ces associations défendaient pas
non plus des des des des terroristes sûr
pas en train de dire ça Florent
vadiillot votre avis là-dessus est-ce
que ces associations finalement de
défend des je vais simplifier des
demandeurs d'asile est-ce qu'elle manque
de discernement c'est on pourrait dire
aussi de toute façon c'est pas à elle de
faire une enquête pour savoir qui elle
défendent c'estétat de le faire mais ces
associations elles mènent un combat
politique pour une vision de l'accueil
de l'Immigration et de l'asile donc on
ne peut pas reprocher à des associations
de faire ce pourquoi elles se sont
constituées et qu'elles font légalement
dans le respect de la législation et en
lien avec les autorités donc je suis
pardonnez-moi de le dire un peu pe
choqué d'entendre ce continuum de quasi
responsabilité des
associations j'ajoute que si l'État a
des des des des doutes avérés sur un
individu lié au renseignement
territorial lié à la police aux
frontières lié au service de
renseignement intérieur il les expulse
on ne peut pas entendre dire et je je le
dis devant Jean-Michel fauver qui qui a
été un très grand policier on peut pas
entendre dire que l'État est faible
qu'il a la main qui tremble lorsqu'il a
des doutes sur des ressortissants
étrangers ça n'est pas vrai que dans les
préfectures des associations se battent
pour des familles qui à l'époque pardon
de le dire n'étaient pas terroristes
elles étaient juste issues d'une région
en guerre que ces associations se se
battent pour cela je trouve que c'est
plutôt noble à l'état ensuite de faire
le suivi nécessaire et de prendre les
mesures de rétorsion qui s'impose et je
crois que ça a été le cas sur le père on
peut s'interroger sur les mesures qui
pourraient peser sur les deux fils
puisque la fraterie est est baigné de
terrorisme mais n'allons pas faire un
lien immédiat entre immigration et
terroriste arithmétiquement
pardon de le dire mais combien de
terroristes sur une sur des générations
d'immigrés et combien de réussites
républicaines absolu dont on ne parle
pas donc je veux bien que le lien soit
fait parce qu'il y a deux auteurs ou
plusieurs auteurs qui sont issus de
l'immigration mais bon S ne faisons pas
un lien systématique entre immigration
et et et et terrorisme c'est le triomphe
du Front national dans ce cas-là Pascal
Perino votre avis et oui oui oui en
effet quand on garde la dernière enquête
de l'Ifop les français au fond le parti
dont il considère qu'il a été le plus en
phase avec l'ampleur des enjeux liés à
la crise israelllo-palestinienne et bien
c'est le rassemblement national hein qui
qui arrive en tête et et est assez loin
loin devant les autres partis donc le
discours mais il faut pas lire ça comme
étant un soutien au rassemblement
national simplement la population
française est à la recherche d'une
fermeté ouais elle veut que sur
certaines questions le débat soit mené
et en particulier on en parlait tout à
l'heure euh à propos de la population
Tchen ou issu du Caucase euh les
Français se rendent bien compte que il y
a dans les différents flux migratoires
des communautés euh qui n'ont pas été
sensibles au processus d'intégration
républicaine mené entre autres par
l'école et que la communauté euh Tchen
est une des communautés qui a été pas
dans sa globalité mais qui a été le plus
réticente beaucoup d'enseignants vous le
disent et vous voyez bien que cet
individu qui a assassiné Dominique
Bernard est arrivé à l'âge de 5 ans en
France donc il a été pendant une
quinzaine d'années soumis au message de
l'école publique qui est un message de
tolérance de pluralisme de respect de
respect de l'autre et on voit que cela
n'a rien fait ça n'a absolument pas
imprimé cette question doit être posé
calmement sereinement il y a
certainement des cultures qui sont plus
réticentes au message républicain et on
peut pas s'étonner que le message
républicain soit dominant dans le cadre
de l'Hexagone tout
même non la fermeté c'est c'est pas
juste d'expulser un tel un tel à mon
avis la fermeté elle commence ailleurs
elle est notamment dans ce qui pourrait
permettre à l'État et au service de
renseignement de surveiller davantage
tout ce qui qui tous les échanges toutes
les communications qui se déroulent en
dehors du du téléphone classique vous
savez que ces individus ils se
téléphonent pas ils s'envoient pas des
SMS ils sont sur des messageries pas
forcément crypté mais les réseaux
sociaux WhatsApp Facebook Instagram tout
ce que vous voulez je pense que si et
aujourd'hui en fait la la police les
services de renseignement sont
relativement démunis à cause de la loi
face à ses à ces à ces à ces réseaux
sociaux et là on s'aperçoit que c'est
quelqu'un l'individu qui apparemment
monte la tête de celui qui passe à pris
ou il est en prison et il utilise ses
réseaux sociaux donc il y a deux points
noirs le premier sont les réseaux
sociaux très vite le deuxè ce sont les
prisons qui sont aujourd'hui devenus le
principal incubateur dans cette
république de l'islamisme militant alors
sans sans faire de de de
lien ou d'amalgame entre immigration et
terrorisme je vous reprends évidemment
Florent vadiillot il y a quand même la
question des conditions
d'expulsion de voilà de cette famille
qui se pose on a on est remonté jusqu'en
2014 on va écouter ce que dit Gérald
armanin c'est le ministre
de l'Intérieur il rappelle d'abord ce
que dit le texte actuel sur la capacité
ou non d'expulser dans le cas précis en
France si vous êtes arrivé sur le
territoire national avant l'âge de 13
ans si vous êtes marié sur le territoire
national avec une Française si vous avez
des enfant nés en France il y a des
protections que seule la loi fr la loi
française évoque très clairement dans la
loi loi qui vous empêche de vous
expulser sauf si vous êtes vous touchez
aux intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
donc le terrorisme ce n'était pas le cas
de cette personne don je rappelle qu'il
n'avait pas de casier judiciaire qui
était suivi par les services de
renseignement depuis moins de 3 mois et
pour lequel nous n'avions que des
soupçon et aucune preuve d'être en lien
avec une entreprise terroriste St journa
nous a rejoint pour pour nous dire ce
que cette attentat d'aras pourrait
changer dans notre droit justement pas
mal de choses hein si le suspect de
l'attentat n'a pas pu être expul c'est
plutôt alors même qu'il était fiché s on
l'a entendu c'était c'est qu'il est
arrivé en France avant 13 ans or en
Paris cas la loi interdit son expulsion
il est protégé en raison de son âge
cette limite d'â limite d'âge
précisément le gouvernement veut la
faire sauter le texte immigration qui
sera examiné le 6 novembre au Sénat
prévoit et bien d'autoriser la
reconduite à la frontière des étrangers
en situation irrégulière menaçant
gravement l'ordre public y compris y
compris c'est important lorsqu'ils ont
des liens personnels et familiaux en
France donc peu importe leur âge peu
importe leur statut personnel Thain
est-ce que ce texte peut-être adopté par
le Parlement en tout cas la majorité
présidentielle veut aller vite veut
aller très vite ce matin la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale parle d'une
adoption avant Noël
écoutezla nous avons un débat
parlementaire nous avons la capacité
aujourd'hui par la voix d'amendement moi
je vois des commentaires à droite et à
gauche les parlementaires les personnes
qui parlent aujourd'hui sont
parlementaires Bruno rotaillot et
parlementaires au Sénat qu' ose des
amendements Marine Le Pen est
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale
éic soioti est parlementaire ils peuvent
déposer des amendements nous avons
l'opportunité d'avoir un texte qui
serait voté avant la fin de l'année nous
pouvons agir dans les de mois qui
viennent et moi je demande à chacun
d'être responsable dans les de mois
c'est une adoption au pas de course
encore faut-il que la droite sénateurel
notamment soit d'accord pas évident
expulser plus vite expulseer mieux sur
ce point le groupe LR ici au Sénat est
d'accord en revanche hors de question
d'adopter un texte qui comporterait la
fameuse régularisation vous savez des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en totion c'est pourtant ce que
prévoit la loi soumise au Sénat par le
gouvernement à voir si l'exécutif
maintenant qu'il est sous pression est
prêt à lâcher un peu de l'Est sur ce
dossier mais justement la droite demande
au gouvernement d'aller plus loin sur
cet arsenal législatif oui seulle une
révision constitutionnelle serait
efficace pour expulser les délinquants
étrangers c'est ce qui avance le groupe
LR au Sénat ce lundi un texte prévoyant
une telle révision a été déposé déjà au
mois de mai il pourrait être examiné ici
à la avant la fin de l'année le le
projet prévoit que les Français puissent
se prononcer par référendum sur les
questions relatives à l'entrée et au
séjour des étrangers en France ainsi que
sur le droit à la nationalité leslr qui
tent de prendre Emmanuel Macron à son
propre jeu lui qui on s'en souvient a
appelé il y a quelques semaines à
élargir le champ du référendum merci
beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour tous ces
détails Pascal Perino il nous reste
quelques minutes le temps à filer très
vite mais
euh ce ce cet électrochoc provoqué par
la mort du professeur Daras va obliger
le gouvernement à aller peut-être un peu
plus loin vers la droite de l'chiquet
politique oui parce que si vous voulez
le gouvernement et c'est légitime il
regarde les évolutions de l'opinion il
regarde les enquêtes et là on voit qu'il
y a à la fois une inquiétude et une
inquiétude extrêmement profonde et
d'autre part des demandes des demandes
d'efficacité
d'autorité les Français sont pas naïfs
ils savent très bien qu'il y aura à
nouveau des attentats mais là
véritablement en une semaine les
Français ont l'impression qu'on a
dépassé en dehors des frontières et au
sein des frontières le stade de
l'horreur et là ils veulent une réaction
et cette réaction en effet favorise
davantage si vous voulez les forces qui
sont à droite de l'échiquier politique
j'allais dire la sensibilité de droite
au sein de la majorité
que les les sensibilités de gauche qui
par rapport à ces questions j'allais
dire historiquement sont moins à l'aise
un dernier mot fréric Ploquin dans dans
dans dans les semaines qui viennent la
police va être en première ligne comme
d'habitude mais la police est toujours
en première ligne la
police si vous voulez il y a il y a un
mois on l' sommet de régler la question
du trafic de stupéfiants en France et
d'arrêter les règlements de compte de
cette urgence absolue qui existait il y
a un mois on passe à une autre urgence
absolue aujourd'hui peut-être il y en
aura-il une trisième après-demain la
police c'est un peu le le dernier
rempart de la République et c'est
probablement l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles euh outre les professeurs
l'école euh les terroristes s'en
prennent régulièrement à la police quand
ils ont fini quand ils ont tué le le
professeur s'ils arrivent à s'échapper
ils vont sortir dans la rue et qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont chercher un policier il va
falloir tuer un policier et tout tous
Voilà c'est c'est c'est l'ennemi de
l'homme à abattre donc effectivement la
police c'est un peu le le dernier
rempart de la République on termine
là-dessus merci beaucoup je cite votre L
livre frédri plquin les réseaux secrets
de la police justement livre c'est une
histoire des solidarités internes à la
police sur la sous la 5e République de
Charles pascoy Nicolas Sarkozi en
passant par Gérard daranin merci
beaucoup et ça sort donc ce mercredi aux
éditions Nouveau Monde merci fréric
plquin Jean-Michel faut et votre livre
les hommes en noir récit de vos
années au c'est un roman c'est un roman
qui s'inspire de des faits que que l'on
connaît des faits réels mais avec une
une une évolution dans dans dans le
récit véritablement romancé à lire aux
éditions plomb merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous dis à
bientôt sur public scat deé que demain
l'invité de Dorian mansini dans sa
matinale c'est brunootillot le président
du groupe LR les républicains ici au
Sénat bonne
[Musique]
soirée